welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and in Ahsoka episode 5 was Anakin
Skywalker ahsoka's own subconscious
memory of a mentor in her mind or the
ghostly trace of Darth Vader the good
and the bad of Vader reconnecting with
Ahsoka from outside of her mind from the
world Between Worlds I believe that the
world Between Worlds was real in this
episode but really how much of Darth
Vader in this episode was ahsoka's
impression of him and how much of him
came from Real force-fueled History
beyond what Ahsoka has control over
because coming on this episode we still
don't really know what he was I guess it
really just comes down to the question
of did Hayden Christensen play the
memory of Anakin Skywalker or the ghost
of Darth Vader and I know you could say
ghosts are kind of memories in a
metaphysical sense but I think coming
out of this episode we need to know if
Anakin was kind of a dream or something
that took place outside of ahsoka's mind
to be clear I think both are going on in
my breakdown of the episode I made the
case for how Anakin is mostly ahsoka's
subjective memory of him at times
playing the role of a Shadow Warrior
wearing a performative mask of evil
Anakin and Invader in order to teach
Ahsoka the lesson that she doesn't come
from a cursed Legacy of failed mentors
but really just mentorships that were
incomplete as the mentors died or fell
to the dark side before they could teach
their Apprentice when to pull their
punches but there were also specific
moments in which I believe the actual
independent ghost of Darth Vader Creeps
in from the outside hijacks a scenario a
spirit from Beyond posed in a very real
physical threat to Ahsoka in this cosmic
space so it's not just ahsoka's own mind
it's mostly ahsoka's own mind but a mind
that occasionally opens itself back up
to the demon of Vader and that demon is
reaching in to grab the wheel much of
what Ashoka experiences with Anakin in
episode 5 does seem to be her Mind's Eye
of her old Master he definitely is a
projection from her memory from the time
of right before the events of Revenge of
the Sith that's why he's surprised to
see her older at first and why when she
recalls the siege of Mandalore from
Clone Wars season 7 the events that
Anakin was imprisoned for because they
were concurrent with the rest of the
events of Revenge of the Sith this
memory of Anakin does not recognize the
battle I don't know this battle
this was the siege of Mandalore
parted Ways by now but
bites you
heard that before what is Anakin
referring to with this line if not what
Luke tells Vader in Return of the Jedi I
will not fight you father so Ahsoka is
set five or six years after the events
of Return of the Jedi but if this Anakin
here is ahsoka's impressionistic memory
of Anakin from before the events of
Revenge of the Sith someone who didn't
recognize the siege of Mandalore because
he was not there for it then how could
he know what lay before him in his
future conflict with his son during the
Battle of Endor does this projection of
Anakin even know that he has a son or a
daughter but while we mentioned it
Ahsoka would not know
Return of the Jedi she obviously wasn't
there for it either one possible
explanation is that Luke Skywalker
sometime after the events of Return of
the Jedi might have told Ahsoka about
that moment and then she buried it in
her subconscious for Anakin here to
bring it up we know that Luke and Ahsoka
knew each other at least from the book
of Boba Fett chapter six we've taught
him well it's more like he's remembering
that I'm actually teaching a little
thing sometimes the student guides the
master This Moment In the book of Boba
Fett was not the first time they met and
it was implied that at some point they
talked about Anakin sometimes I wonder
if his heart is in it so much like your
father what should I do about him trust
your instincts so Ahsoka might know from
Luke but this exchange with Anakin I've
heard that before it's just so textually
specific that I just don't know if Luke
would have given Ahsoka a word for word
transcript of what went down and I just
think it's kind of a reach that Ahsoka
might remember it well enough for Anakin
to draw it back up for this moment so
yeah I probably overthought this too
much I think we all agree here that this
line must have come from Beyond ahsoka's
understanding and of course we are in
the world Between Worlds it is a cosmic
dimension in which all points in time
and space are linked by the force
described as a conduit between life and
death when Ezra Bridger walked through
it he heard all kinds of phrases echoing
through time from sources he would have
had no idea about some sources hadn't
even been born yet like Rey kylo Ren Bo
Dameron so this must mean that Anakin in
this space is at least in part for some
specific moments being hijacked by the
actual Spirit of Anakin or Vader that is
Tethered to this Dimension by the force
despite Vader's actions throughout his
life this link persists and it's why
Anakin was still able to come back as
the Force ghost at the end of her turn
the Jedi and George Lucas made it very
clear that he wants us to see him as
Hayden Christensen while Dave filoni and
other animators have clarified that the
world between world is a subjective
experience unique to the Jedi who visits
it in that particular moment it's also
about their connection to a wider Cosmos
that they do not understand all of yet
everybody is connected to this by the
force this video is sponsored by raid
Shadow Legends imagine if you could
transform your world just by snapping
your fingers like see now I'm an
Intergalactic Bean of light and now with
raid's new mythical Champions you can
use a special mechanic called metamorph
to switch between two different forms
Champions emerge from their
metamorphosis with the new form new
skills and a new look mythical Champions
are basically two champions in one and
you can switch between both forms as you
play making them the most versatile
champions in raid both forums use the
same artifacts accessories masteries and
blessings and can be summoned using
brand new Red Primal shards mythical
Champions are a great reason to download
raid if you haven't already new players
can get a stag night with a custom
JonTron skin just by using the promo
code JT skin before October 7th new and
returning players who log on seven
different days between now and October
23rd can get Sun Wukong a legendary
champion for free and if you use the
link in the description or scan the QR
code you'll get insane bonuses like an
epic Champion Drake plus energy refills
a skill Tome and an XP booster so click
the link in the description to start
playing raid today and so this
projection of Anakin is really a fusion
of what Ahsoka has brought to the table
with her subconscious and the ghosts of
the past and of the future that are
already waiting for her there this
cannot all be in ahsoka's head of course
because Jason cindula and even Hera
through her son are able to hear Ahsoka
and Anakin's lightsaber clashes they
don't know where Ahsoka is at that
moment so they're not just like reading
her mind and what she's experiencing in
that moment they are hearing the realm
itself Jason hears it in the water now
with a title like Shadow Warrior I think
it's really important to brush up on our
Akira Style to best understand this
episode Shadow Warrior comes from
kurosawa's 1980 film kagemusha about a
political decoy and I posed in the
breakdown that when Anakin turns into
Vader it's kind of Anakin wearing a veil
of Vader as a decoy to give Ahsoka a way
to complete her incomplete duel with
Vader on malachor George Lucas left
karasawa and he based the original Star
Wars on kurosawa's 1958 the Hidden
Fortress among many other influences but
really one of kurosawa's most important
films especially for this episode of
Ahsoka is 1950s rashamon a story about
contradicting memories of a single event
and how memory itself is really biased
and subjective no no I remember it
things happen in ahsoka's memories of
ryloth and the siege of Mandalore that
probably did not actually happen
according to the historical record on
ryloth she Witnesses Anakin flashed in
the Darth Vader if that actually
happened if young Asoka actually saw
that on rylock during Clone Wars season
1 their relationship would have gone
differently like it wasn't until the
mortis Arc in season 3 that Ahsoka began
worrying about what would become of her
master in the future so really what
Young Ahsoka was seen in this moment was
just adult Ahsoka thinking back on this
moment and the world between world to
toying with her with what the future
would bring because there is something
important about this shot that connects
with pretty much every other one of the
evil Anakin flashes in this episode he
faces away from Ahsoka like we do not
get a good look of his face he's
surrounded by fog he's partially
obscured both times he introduces the
liver die lesson his back is turned to
Ahsoka on the word live and he faces her
on die what's the lesson Master live
or die back to the beginning I gave you
a choice
live
or die on ryloth when he counsels child
warrior Ahsoka he says this pretty dark
line what if I want to stop fighting and
you'll die and he steps away and turns
as he says the word die initially on the
siege of Mandalore we get the slow
approach to ahsoka's back her back is
turned to Anakin in this moment of
course we have his March into the fog on
ryloth when he flickers innovator and
actually you could link this moment with
Anakin reappearing through the fog back
into the world Between Worlds he
flickers into Vader and right here
Ahsoka doesn't really see a close-up of
his face it's not until he says black
conviction and his voice is now a mix of
Anakin and Vader human and robotically
filtered reminding us of Matt lanter's
voice mixed with James Earl Jones's
voice and that duel on malachor in
Rebels honestly you lack conviction
isn't really the meanest or most evil
thing and it could say right here it's
still the words of a master trying to
help a student and when they are close
in combat it does seem kind of evil when
Anakin says Fine to die he's got those
fiery red eyes yeah yeah yeah but I
think this is Anakin the master playing
the part to make a point to Ahsoka in
his live or die lesson he's warning her
right now that if you let this rage take
over you you're gonna be on a path at
least to death so when she Corners him
the way he cornered Dooku she makes a
different choice and she proves that she
has learned the lesson and that there is
hope for her yes so I think really the
best way to see what happened in this
episode is the world Between Worlds was
totally real here the force used
ahsoka's aquatic surroundings to build
this construct but now it has a Bluer
more fluid texture because it is made up
of the pieces of water that it melts
back down to when she leaves it Ahsoka
populated this temporary construct with
her own subconscious memories but those
memories got occasional boosts from the
force to be more effective using
costumes and masks and props and yes
even script lines to produce this
theatrical performance all supplied from
the force from All Points in history to
teach the lesson to Ahsoka that she
needed to learn please support new rock
stars by grabbing this Ahsoka inspired
fulcrum shirt at nerd riot.shop
subscribe to all three channels of the
new rockstars Network you can follow me
at eavos following rockstars thanks for
watching I'll see you next time bye
[Music]